so one of the biggest issues of our time
is one of the issues where the United
States internationally is no longer
really a participant in the discussion
they're no longer really at the table
thanks to Donald Trump and that topic is
climate change the climate crisis is now
it's not some vague thing in the future
people are dying from climate change and
pollution related issues right now now
is when we are either going to figure it
out or not figure it out and continue to
fall further and further behind more and
more urgently behind in figuring this
out it's a national security issue it's
a moral issue it's a a physical issue
with regard to the physical health
impact that climate change has on humans
and animals on this planet and
biodiversity of the non animal kind as
well and Donald Trump has been clear
climate change is a hoax created by the
Chinese it's not a problem the US is out
of the Paris climate Accords so other
countries have to take the lead it's not
the u.s. who's going to do it and so now
if you want to be at the forefront of
fighting climate change you don't go to
the u.s. you go to China you go to India
and you go to other countries and this
is becoming a vicious circle a sort of
self-fulfilling or self-perpetuating
prophecy Trump simply didn't go to
yesterday's g7 meeting about the climate
this was the place to talk about the
Amazon rainforest fires which by the way
the g7 said we're gonna throw 20 million
at it there are movies as has been
pointed out on Twitter that have budgets
that are more than five times the amount
of money that these seven countries are
saying we will devote to the Amazon fire
issue this was the meeting about cutting
carbon emissions about dealing with the
crisis that is now which is climate
change Trump just wasn't there
Trump was later asked why weren't you at
the climate session he said oh we're
having it in a little while
a reporter tried to explain to him that
it's in the past it already happened
time moves forward and Trump didn't seem
to hear him but he says we have the
cleanest air and the cleanest water on
the planet which is of course both
ridiculous and untrue
you may find extension there any
conclusions that you could come over to
in fact it's going to be our next
session but we haven't had it to get the
message that you'd like to deliver so
you know i want clean air and clean
water well right now having to clean
this air and clean this water on the
planet but that's what I want I want
absolutely clean air and clean water
living in a complete fantasy world as
usual and it was later reported that
Trump wasn't there but someone from his
team was a French president McCrone also
said oh I did broach the topic of the
fires with Trump and Trump wants the
fires put out so okay that there's that
now I hate to admit this because I want
the United States to be part of the
climate change discussion we're one of
the biggest users of fossil fuels we
have to be part of the solution but
there's probably way more progress to be
made when Donald Trump is not
participating the guy suggested bombing
hurricanes to stop them the guy thinks
climate change is a hoax created by
China what can you really add to a
discussion about climate change and
unfortunately the reality is that Donald
Trump's constituents only make this more
feasible you've got the people who just
don't understand climate change so they
don't believe in it
you've got the partisan hacks who just
think it's a matter of opinion and
liberals are wrong because they want to
be on the other opposite side of
liberals you've got the religious nuts
who believe God would never make it
possible for humans to hurt the planet
and then you've got like the business
and industry people who probably believe
climate change and accept the science
but they recognize that their businesses
potentially become less profitable if we
take climate change seriously and so you
have this perfect constituency to do
nothing about climate change and to feel
good and justified about doing nothing
either because they're owning the libs
or because of God or because of whatever
else now I understand why Trump didn't
go to the meeting I'm more left
wondering why Trump even went to the g7
his big contribution was bringing
Melania who got media attention for
kissing Emmanuel macron
for suggesting Russia be allowed back
into the g7 which we'll talk about a
little bit later Trump did nothing else
notable in the positive sense right why
do these [ __ ] Europeans keep talking
about things like climate and nuclear
weapons in the environment and trade
what about golf scores and mar-a-lago
Trump should really just stop going and
I hate to say it because the u.s. not
being a participant short term is a very
very bad thing
but my thought is this guy is adding
nothing and he's just embarrassing us
maybe the next president can start
showing up and actually participating in
more of a productive and respectable way
I believe that we are actually at that
point where Trump just shouldn't even go
to this stuff let me know if you agree
disagree with me I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show and of course we are now on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
make sure you follow us there and
subscribe free with twitch prime if
you've got an Amazon Prime account
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
forward slash
tak ma n